what I think is proving to be true is if
you are a freelancer or you're somebody
who has worked in this way you
understand how to maintain a network
whether you do it on Facebook or you
just do it yourself that's really
critical that you know how to pitch work
so that a company may lay people off but
there's still certain things that are
going to need to get done and you can
figure out where that's going to be and
you can get in you can make your pitch
and you can get that job where you know
how to manage your money during times of
feast and famine all the things I've
said are like freelancing a be the ABCs
of freelancing and so it puts people who
have those experiences at an advantage
right now and so we're not seeing that
our members are getting it's hard hit as
traditional workers right now their
incomes are definitely going lower and
the ones whose work or evaporating
literally are going to go on welfare you
know that really it's it's it's scary
but as a group I think that's something
that is going to stand anybody in good
stead especially now but going forward
so there I wouldn't say that you know Oh
everybody should learn to be a
programmer it's in technology like I
don't I think it's more the skill set of
those kinds of of that kind of work it's
going to become the most important thing
you know it's funny when we chart out
our membership it like just completely
dovetails with Richard Florida's work so
for us it's you know New York the parts
of New Jersey like Jersey City Hoboken
Philadelphia Austin Texas sprawling part
of florida miami etc California Oregon
Washington State Illinois Chicago and I
think that it's a number of things where
it is going to be that you know sort of
hard core knowledge economy base but
also when you talk to people in these
worlds they really are thinking about
sustainability they really are talking
about the do-it-yourself notions the
idea that you really do have to do it
yourself because you can't have faith
that it's going to be done for you and
that's where again it's not at the level
of being an atom it's that you realize I
must join with in a group because that's
the only way that one will survive and
do well and so I do think it is going to
be that clustering and then when you
think about the just the resources of
what it takes to live in the suburbs
it's just it's just very difficult
that's not to say like all suburbs are
going to like shrivel up and die but I
just think it's less and less
sustainable and its alienating